ja schon das billigste auf der Karte
bestellt das teuerste auf der Karte
bestellt die Empfehlung des Kellners
genommen und heute das mit den
Lieferdienst entscheiden was er uns
bringen möchte ganz einfach wir rufen
ansagen echt bringt einfach was ihr
wollt und sie bringen uns das dann und
ich hoffe das wird lecker sein wird mir
sehr unproblematisch was Essen angeht
auf jeden Fall hoffe ich dass ich ganz
viele Sachen entdecken kann heute und
wir fangen an mit dem ersten Gericht
unser erster Sport Karl Hermanns wer das
vorletzte Video gesehen hat weiß ist ein
Burgerladen und werde mal anrufen und
fragen ob sie Lust haben mir einfach
irgendwas für Mifa
ja schön guten Tag hier eine Frage
liefert ihr selbst oder nur über
Lieferando oder so okay alles klar weiß
Bescheid danke schön
ja schön guten Tag Frage liefert ihr
selbst oder nur über Lieferando okay
alles klar weiß ich Bescheid danke schön
Ciao
ja hallo frage liefert ihr nur über
Lieferando oder auch selbst
ey digga ich dachte wirklich ich würde
keinen Lieferservice mehr finden der
selbst liefert aber
ja Hallo kurze Frage liefert ihr selbst
oder nur über
lieferando.de ganz zufällig dazu Fragen
aber anscheinend hat der Bock als sie
haben jetzt bei einem indischen
Restaurant angerufen bei ginti und
ähnlich habe ich das noch gar nicht
gehabt auf dem Channel hier mag ich aber
sehr gerne und bin gespannt was er uns
bringen wird dann kriegen wir gleich
irgendwas zufälliges gebracht
es ist relativ
ich bin noch gesagt extra das auch nicht
schlimm ist wenn es scharfes und so
haben sich entscheiden zu Herzen
genommen nicht schlimm scharf aber
probieren ob es chillig sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
coursera butterzart aber dachte ich
wahrscheinlich sauer wenn der alman
jetzt sagt schlaf ruhig schaffe dann
machen wir mal richtig scharf sind nur
W10 Chilis drin oder so wieso ist an
sich auch ja ja ich muss gleich mal
nachschauen was die Nummer bedeutet aber
wünsch Fleisch zart und das Ding ist ich
weiß nur wenig über die indische Küche
dass mir das niemals selbst bestellt
haben könnte ich habe irgendwie so ein
Basic bestellten dass sie das jetzt
bekommen habe obwohl ich noch
rausstellen was ist
er hat geantwortet es ist chicken Madras
chicken mal was ist ein Curry aus
Südindien es setzt auf die Tränen
treibende Schärfe von Chilis in einer
Soße auf der Basis von Tomaten
für Chili
direkt die nächste Mahlzeit
ja hallo ich wollte nicht ganz gerne
eine Bestellung aufgeben bei dir so für
25 € aber du kannst mich gerne damit
überraschen also einfach bringen worauf
du Lust hast
super danke schön freue mich
dafür einfach ja wir
lieben Dank
das ist kein Spaß dass ihr von mir seht
ich habe angerufen gerade eben hat
gesagt
25/25
gesagt von YouTube Video drehen oder so
ne nur gesagt 20 € ich glaube vielleicht
ist das dann auch so geil für die Leute
dass die so eine so eine Aufgabe suchen
und es möglich beste präsentieren wollte
aber wir haben dazu auch noch zwei
verschiedene Getränke einmal ein Ayran
mit Gewürzen auch nie getrunken und
einen sauren berberitzensaft
ich kannte das nicht
[Musik]
wirklich sehr saftig tadik Reis schön
mit Kruste mit Safran
[Musik]
alter Schwede erst wieso wieso ein
persischer Gulasch Linsen aber auch
Gewürze die man gar nicht so kennt
dann
trotzdem so
einfach so
zwischendurch
[Musik]
und wer krank ist Essen berberitzensaft
Berberitzen kennen viele Leute glaube
ich gar nicht so richtig so sauere
kleinen Bärchen
track and the Allrad man denkt nicht
nett probier mal
bitte ganz wenig
[Musik]
ja wo ich will nur food Videos mache
habe irgendwann mal alles probiert und
so aber man kann immer was neues
probieren deshalb liebe ich solche
Videos wir essen das ganze auf und dann
komme ich zur nächsten Bestellung Nummer
3 die letzte Bestellung freue mich drauf
ja schönen guten Tag hier Max würde
gerne eine Bestellung aufgeben zum
liefern
das würde ich ganz Ihnen überlassen
irgendwas für eine Person so sag mal bis
25 € ich würd mich gerne überraschen
lassen
nee bitte nicht
super herzlichen Dank
[Musik]
Karton und es ist keine Pizza
oben in der Ecke Schnitzel es ist
einfach ein Schnitzel im Pizzakarton
dann haben wir hier ein bisher bekommen
ein Apfelstrudel mit Vanillesoße
hier drin haben wir das in einem
Restaurant
Speck Spiegelei und Zwiebeln crazy und
hier drüben haben wir Bratkartoffeln
Schnitte anzünden Abschluss
extra knusprig
es ist natürlich eine komplette
Eskalation Smart hat wenn ich mir bei
anderes bestimmt irgendwie am Sonntag
wenn ich weiß die heute geht gar nichts
mehr aber dazu
wenn du gelieferten Spiegelei saufen das
Eigelb isst du bekommst wirklich nur
ganz andere Sache und dazu noch so
schöne große Zwiebeln
Fünffache Portion Bratkartoffeln allein
das ist schon genug um mich dazu
bekommen Ratten unter der Lieferung
gelitten aber man sieht ihn an dass er
knusprig waren
natürlich vor dem Hintergrund
mal
irgendwas von diesem
challenges ich mache einfach sagen ey
bring mir was ihr wollt oder ich hätte
gerne das billigste auf der Karte das
teuerste auf der Karte das macht
wirklich Spaß und dann erweitert dadurch
auch wirklich sein habe ich zwar
gewonnen wird schon ihren Kamera
festgehalten muss auch unproblematisch
sein was die Sachen angeht die du isst
aber Apfelstrudel Hermann ertränken hier
in der Vanillesoße
[Musik]
willst du dann noch sagen Eltern kannst
du mich nicht sagen dass mich so viel
Apfel drin das schmeckt richtig richtig
doll nur Apfel voll und ganz leichte
Vanillesoße Feierabend Wer ist das alles
auch Leute Dank fürs zuschauen dann
wieder mega Spaß gemacht bis zum
nächsten Video mach's gut und schau